バンカ
[音楽]
ラジオふも大きくてかこ
いいそんな
にあは先生にいたずらしよういいねチョク
が欲しいな僕の家お金持ちだからチ
たくさん買ったよゆく来て行く
よしでき
たいいねいい
ね
[音楽]
よし
生徒やっ
[拍手]
てくなんだ
うは先生様子が変だよチ
ぱいそう甘い先生は生徒たちへの憎しみを
利用されクの魔人とかしてしまったので
あっ
[拍手]
たチクの魔人は様々なものを白く
塗りつぶすため街にくりてしまっ
た街の平和は俺が守る花の穴でかですチク
の魔人が街中を白く塗りつぶし混乱を極め
てい
ます
変身天才ですから天才
[音楽]
エロー
くそ動きを止めなきゃ魔人の因はんだった
ん
だそうか先生ごめん
ね本当は先生を尊敬してるよ今後は言う
ことを聞き
ます今
だだからなこれでとめだ
ビームま全部言うこと聞くかは分からない
けど
[音楽]
ねデブ博士やったよよくやったねこの世界
に悪の組織ズそいつらは人の悪の感情を
使って人間を魔人化させる彼らを秘密に
倒すのが我々バカレンジャーの仕事なのだ
からあえそしてヒーローは絶対に正体を
ばらしてはいけないよ分かってるってじゃ
ね天才
[音楽]
ろなんかしっくり来ないんだよな
天才
ろ天才
ろあんた何してんの
えもう小学校3年生
でしょいい加減ヒロもはいいんじゃない
いや嫌じゃなくて遊んでないで片付けとか
さ忙しいから
無理忙しくないでしょ
あんたそれダサいわよお前が
なお前がなお前がなお前が
お前学校行ってき
ますあのこったら全然言うこと聞いてくん
ないわああもうイライラするイライラする
もう痛体も痛いし年金も少ないし
キやるてくおはようあおはようおはよう
おはようやか
うんんどうしたのかっこ
いいキータ君があのヒーローなんだって謎
のヒーローによりチョクの真面目は倒され
ましたこの町の平和は守られたのですま実
はあれ俺なんだよねそれはおそして
ヒーローは絶対に体をらしとけよあなんで
もないあれれヒの俺に憧れちゃった
チキヒーローなんて運だよ変身は出さいっ
て言われるし俺の偽物まで出てくるしもう
ヒロてやめ
たいいことがないのいいことがない
[拍手]
の
はいやすまた新たな魔人が現れた倒しに
行くんだ嫌ですそれじゃあ街の平和
がはいグ始めるぞはい始めるぞはい今日は
国語です国語の
授業大きなワがいまし
て体中が痛くて鬱憤が溜まったおばあ
ちゃん魔人が現れました破壊ゲームでの節
や人の節を破壊してい
ます倒しに行ってよ
えっと早く僕たち守って
よお前ヒーローなんだろ行けよぼ僕が
ヒーローだ
うえええええええやっぱり怖いよでも
かかってこい完
ム関節
がほらお前が倒すんだろその声はやす助け
て
くそ
ビーブ
ガ
ビなかなか手怖いなキーた鼻くそだせえ
ヒーローなんだろここに1年間貯めた
鼻クソ
[音楽]
が
じゃおばあちゃんは関節の痛みでストレス
を抱えてたんだこのハメに見れてるうちに
エロー
[音楽]
ビー
その後キーターデブハに認められて
スーパーヒーローになりひっつきはくの
能力を手に入れた僕の能力の引く
で接
[音楽]
[拍手]
くっつけあの魔人からマを守ったのは君の
おかげなんでしょいやいやヒーローなんか
じゃないけど
ねおい実は俺もすしパレちゃいけないん
だろす君は関係ないんだから入らない
で俺が倒したのになん
で様まもバレにマシれました面白いな
バレ次は内側から破壊して
[音楽]
やろ
[拍手]
いい歌ゆうたの蓋ももでかくてかっこいい
まゆと君私可愛いからゆと君の持ってる
でかい鉛筆ちょうだいえなんでてか可愛
いってか普通ぐらいじゃねでも私美少女
小学生って逃走中でも書かれてたよ女子
1人でテレビサがも調したくてそういう
名前をつけただけであって勘違いしない方
がもう嫌い
ムカつくムカつくムカつくムカつく
ムカつくムカつく私は可愛く服装とか木を
使ってるのにバカでぼーっとしてる大事に
言われたくない
[音楽]
不ちゃんちゃんだだきーちゃんきーちゃん
なんだんだと思うこんちゃんちゃんカエル
はです
ねこの問題分かる人あいないの
か私わからないまこじりちゃんは分から
ないよな可愛いからいい
よこじちゃん大好き僕のお金持ちだからお
金あげるよ2人ともどうした
の人類は皆私にメロメロなの
だはく見られたいと
いう
まずい魔化した行く
ぞがいことを言っちゃったせ
でにより国家はし放送メロメになりのしか
れなくなってい
ます内はパニックに陥ってい
ますいた
ぞ鼻くそ攻撃エロビームタクどもじ
様
捉えろメロメロ
ビームかじり可愛いこじり可愛いままずい
イネスもねメロメロ
[音楽]
ビームゆうと本当は思ってもないのにジし
ちゃってごめんこじりえそうかこじりを
褒めろえこんちゃんこんちゃん可愛い
可愛いこんちゃんこんちゃん可愛い可愛い
こんちゃんこんちゃん可愛い可愛いこじり
は自信がなくなってただけだゆうと
行けこじり実は俺可愛いこじりのことが
大好きなんだ
大好きだから意地悪しちゃったごめんえ
あり
うス今だ
ラビーム私何やってたんだろうゆと君私に
何か言ったっけえいやなんでもないよそっ
か
じお前はいい加減元に
戻れ君たちには質があるヒーローになって
くれいいよでもいつになったらこの戦いは
終わるのワイズのボスNを倒すことだN彼
が悪の根源まどこにいるのか本当に存在
するのかすら分からないのだ
がお菓子ばっか食ってちゃんと仕事してよ
ね誰がお菓子ばっか食ってるだっ
てN様またしてもならばとっておきの魔人
を行かせるか行くが
[音楽]
よいはいえセロ主は太地にとってどのよう
な存在だろう太地と物のえ魚はねえどんな
情であっても情に等しい強敵が来た次は
やすのお母さんそう最強の母が魔人化した
早く行ってくれみんなでだ行くぞ
おでくっついて俺のマントで止めく
ぞえええええって
だ
最強のママ魔人です文字通り最強です
シンプルな破壊光線で街を焼きつくし
ながら進んでいます皆さんは避難を今回は
相当で怖いぞ僕のパワと私のメロメロ
コンセント奥のくっつき鼻くそで絶対
勝てるよそうだ全員の呼吸をぴったり
合わせればパワーは最大になる勝てる
ぞ
天才ですから
天才森のようにでっかいル
グリーンる草さそブルーメロメロにし
ちゃうぞプリティ
ピンク
[音楽]
合わせロービーム鼻クソ
攻撃
メロメロ
ビーム私女だから効かない
わかレンジャー
だろうの強そうだろクズの方が渋くていい
だろ際よそりはもうすでにあるだろこう
なったら修行だバンカ
レンジャーバンカレンジャーその後バンカ
レンジャーはを合わせてパワーを最大する
ために修行する
のっ
バカ日本の半分が滅しましたこの世の
終わり
です
全圧て小学戦隊バングレジャー
う早く言えやすお母さん大好き産んでくれ
てありがとう
大好き
あうなんでこんな思ってもないこと言わ
なきゃいけないんだ早く続けてお母さん
いつもありがとう2人の顔かいた
[音楽]
よ
もっと可愛くかかなきゃこれ使えお
[音楽]
お母さんこれよおお母さんこれかいて
よ息子の愛を感じてでる今がチャンスよ
わバカちゃ
[音楽]
ビ見つけたああ君の読みとり君のお母さん
は魔人化されたその時につけたGPSの
おかげで敵のアジとを見つけることができ
たよあれ
だあれが悪いのアとこの戦いを終わらせる
んだみんな準備はいいかうん転送する
ぞ
見つけたお前がボスのエかさすがな
遅お前の正体はん
だおお前
は
ううた歩くんだ
よ
何が目的だ僕の家お金持ちだから何でも
変えるんだけどお金じゃ買えないものも
あるんだよ
ねそれはなんだ自分で考えてみたなそれ
じゃまたねバイ
[音楽]
バイ学バカレンジャーの戦いはまま
続くちゃちゃチャンネル登録チャンネル
登録チャンネル登録よろしくチャンネル
登録チャンネル登録チャンネル登録
よろしく最はチャンネル登録チャンネル
登録チャンネル
登録